el gobierno británico anunció una sequía
oficial en ocho zonas de Inglaterra
incluida a la ciudad de Londres debido a
que no ha llovido en los últimos meses y
la reservas de agua están en niveles muy
bajos Se esperan temperaturas de 35
grados en los próximos días una sequía
prolongada y por ello el Ministerio del
ambiente ha dado luz verde a las
compañías de agua potable para que
puedan implementar restricciones en el
uso del vital líquido por ejemplo en
zonas residenciales como esta se puede
prohibir el uso de las mangueras para
rociar los jardines también existe una
alerta máxima de incendios debido a que
los jardines y todas las zonas públicas
están en están secas y cualquier chispa
podría originar un incendio y extenderse
a zonas residenciales como lo que vimos
el mes pasado cuando las culturas
llegaron a los 40 grados centígrados y
en este momento Inglaterra está viviendo
la peor sequía desde 1976